REDIKER: Good morning.
I'm Doug Rediker, and I have been told that
I don't need to do the usual "turn off your
devices, et cetera" thing.
So we're going to get right into it this morning,
if I could.
The program is going to be that we're going
to speak with Gavin for about 10 minutes,
and basically let Gavin explain.
This is a complicated and brand-new subject
for a lot of us here.
So we're going to ask Gavin to sort of go
through who he is, how he got here, and what
the heck Bitcoin is all about.
And then I'm going to try and provoke some
interesting responses.
And then hopefully, we'll have provoked enough
from the audience, that we'll get the rest
of the morning to have everybody ask their
questions.
And Gavin will, I'm sure, answer every single
question, so that we'll have no questions
about Bitcoin when we leave.
Maybe we'll get there, maybe we won't.
But let's start with Gavin Andresen, who is
the chief science officer.
ANDRESEN: Chief scientist.
REDIKER: Chief scientist -- no officers in
Bitcoin Foundation -- for the Bitcoin Foundation.
And as I said, Gavin, if you can just sort
of go through who you are, how you got here,
and what in your view succinctly we need to
know about Bitcoin, before we go into some
of the "I don't understand it, so please explain,"
fill in the blank.
ANDRESEN: Sure.
I'm a technology guy.
So I started my career working in Silicon
Valley.
I worked for a company called "Silicon Graphics"
for eight years, creating 3D graphic software.
After that, I actually did a series of startups,
some of which were successful, some of which
were miserable failures.
So kind of a typical, you know, high-tech,
Silicon Valley background.
When my kids were born in the year 2000, I
actually started working half-time, just spend
more time with the kids, kind of step back
from the entrepreneurial, high-tech, start-up
life.
And then in 2010, I stumbled across this interesting
little open-source software project called
"Bitcoin."
And I was kind of looking around for something
to do.
You know, my kids were at an age where I didn't
-- I felt like I could jump into something
more meaty.
And Bitcoin caught my interest.
Bitcoin combined kind of an interest I had
in economics, in computer cryptography, and
in distributed peer-to-peer systems, so systems
where there's no central control.
I decided to do the simplest possible project
I could think of.
I'm a technology guy, so obviously, you know,
if I see some new technology, I want to play
with it.
And I figured a lot of other people would
probably want to play with Bitcoin, too.
But at that time, it wasn't that easy to get
Bitcoin.
And so I decided that the easiest possible
project for me to tackle would be a website
that just gave Bitcoin away.
And so I spent $50 of my own money, and I
bought 10,000 bitcoins.
At that time, bitcoins were selling for about
half-a-penny apiece.
And I started giving bitcoins away at what's
called the "Bitcoin Faucet."
And so turns out, if you give something away,
that's a good way to make people like you.
So a lot of people kind of liked that I was
giving these bitcoins away so people could
play with them, try them, you know, see that
the system worked, see that, you know, their
transactions didn't get lost.
And I slowly got more and more involved in
the project.
I started contributing code to the project,
which at that time, was basically a one-person
project.
I mean, the creator of Bitcoin's this person,
Satoshi Nakamoto, who I won't say upfront,
I'm not Satoshi.
Don't know who Satoshi is.
I haven't met him, or her, or them.
Until at the beginning of 2011, Satoshi decided
to step back from the project, and kind of
push me forward as the lead developer for
this open-source project that was still, back
then, just getting off the ground.
Since then, my life has been kind of endlessly
fascinating.
So all sorts of interesting adventures through
Bitcoin.
And obviously, you know, Bitcoin has been
wildly successful, I hope, partly, because,
you know, I did give away 10,0000 bitcoins
way back then.
I like -- at least, I like to tell myself
that that's part of the reason why Bitcoin
became successful.
It was a way of bootstrapping.
You know, it's a really interesting question,
right.
I mean, bitcoins were worthless when they
were first created.
They had no value, none at all.
You know, when I bought those 10,000 bitcoins
to fund the Bitcoin Faucet, they were worth
under half-a-penny apiece.
I didn't realize that at that time, but it
had just been a few weeks earlier that bitcoins
actually had a price, that there was actually
an exchange where people were starting to
trade bitcoins for dollars.
And that's how we know the price of Bitcoin
is -- these exchanges run by whoever wants
to start an exchange, all over the world,
where people will trade bitcoins for dollars,
or euros, or yen, or whatever other thing
they want to trade bitcoins for.
Today, bitcoins are trading for about $800
apiece.
So those 10,000 bitcoins that I bought back
then, if I had kept them, would be worth about
$8 million today.
The reason bitcoins are valuable, the reason
people want them, are because they're limited
in supply.
There's a purely fixed number of bitcoins
that are being created.
Right now I believe there are about 12 million
bitcoins in existence.
And the rules of the software, the open-source
software that I work on, there will never
be more than 21 million bitcoins in existence.
So this is different than other kinds of money,
where -- you know, we don't know what the
Federal Reserve is going to do next year,
or 10 years from now.
With Bitcoin, there's some certainty, because
it's written in the code, that there shall
only ever be 21 million bitcoins.
We can talk more about how hard and fast is
that rule, what other kinds of rules are there.
But that's basically where Bitcoin gets its
value, right.
We have these digital tokens that people have
decided have some value.
We started with they're worth half-a-penny
apiece.
"I might as well buy some.
Who knows if this project is going to be successful?
If it is, then I'll make a little money, maybe.
If not, then maybe I'll have fun trading it
with my friends, maybe buying some alpaca
socks with my bitcoins."
It's actually alpaca socks were actually one
of the very first physical goods that you
could buy with bitcoins.
And I have a couple pair of alpaca socks that
I bought for bitcoins.
Because the alpaca socks guy actually lives
across the river from me up in Massachusetts.
But that's the way a money works.
I mean, we don't usually think about money
much.
But all moneys are really kind of the shared
delusion that they're valuable because we
say it's valuable, and because there's a fixed
supply, because you can't just -- "Money doesn't
grow on trees, is the saying.
So that's what Bitcoin is.
And that's what Bitcoin has been.
What Bitcoin will become in the future, there's
lots and lots of speculation, because it turns
out, you can use Bitcoin for money, you can
use it as a payment network.
It's incredibly convenient to use Bitcoin
to pay people face-to-face, using your cell
phones, or across the world, which is really
revolutionary.
And there's a lot of value there.
People are more and more talking about Bitcoin
as a network that can support all sorts of
other interesting things that maybe money's
just the first application of this distributed
technology, where there's no central control.
But there is this shared ledger of transactions,
where we all agree that these are the transactions
that took place.
So people are, today, experimenting with using
it for all sorts of other different things.
And so as we go forward, you may start hearing
about Bitcoin as, you know, not just currency,
not just money, not even just a payment network;
but maybe -- maybe a way of signing title
for houses or cars, or doing other kinds of
contracts.
So there's all sorts of innovation that's
happening.
And really, for me as a technology guy, that's
what makes me really excited.
It's all of the interesting things that are
being created on top of this new technology
that -- that, you know, keeps me awake at
night thinking about the possibilities.
REDIKER: All right.
So many questions; those I'd thought about
asking, and now some that just came up.
But I'm not a tech guy.
So as you could see, when I was trying to
raise the font on my iPad, I still have some
problems with the basics.
But if the software is designed in a way that
is reliable, dependable, open-source, et cetera,
what is it that you do when you say, "I go
home, and I write more code for it"?
In other words, are you constantly revising
the underlying computer code, and if so, why?
Does that mean you're making it better, or
did you find flaws in it?
And again, this isn't about Bitcoin in particular,
but just in general, if something is a currency
-- we'll get into what it is, or isn't, or
should be, or could be.
But, you know, when you're the chief scientist,
and you're writing code for something, what
does that mean?
ANDRESEN: Sure.
I mean, I actually get asked that question
a lot.
"Isn't Bitcoin finished?"
You know, "Why do you have to write any code?"
And being a software engineer, software's
never finished, right.
There's always -- you can always optimize
it.
You can always make it a little bit faster.
You can always make it a little bit easier
to use.
As Bitcoin grows, you know, a lot of what
I do, a lot of the work is scaling up, is
-- you know, when there were 10,000 people
trading Bitcoin back and forth, and there
were a few transactions happening every hour,
it's not hard to write software that handles
a few transactions every hour.
REDIKER: So like the Affordable Care Act had
some...
ANDRESEN: Well, they jumped into the deep
end, right.
I mean, Bitcoin's had the luxury of kind of
organically growing at a very -- it's been
a steep path.
And it's been hard to keep up.
But as Bitcoin continues to grow, we just
-- there's software engineering that has to
be done to support thousands of transactions
per second, instead of dozens of transactions
per day.
REDIKER: So it's not changing the fundamentals.
It's simply allowing it to grow organically
or otherwise.
ANDRESEN: Pretty much, yes.
I mean, yes.
Yes.
To the lay person, you know, it would look
like...
(CROSSTALK)
REDIKER: We're all lay people when it comes
to the technology underlying Bitcoin.
ANDRESEN: It typically looks like we're doing
nothing, which is what we want, right.
I mean, we want the system to just work.
REDIKER: All right.
So let's -- the questions -- we spoke last
week.
And I started with the basic skepticism of,
"It's a virtual currency," and we'll get into
what a currency should be, could be, why we
need one, et cetera.
But you pointed out it is both a virtual currency,
a payment system, or a payment network, and
it's regulated in some quarters as a commodity.
So can you go through the -- and let's start
with the payment system, because I think that's
the least controversial, and the one that
I personally am the least skeptical about.
I think it certainly adds value with limited
controversy.
Can you just go through how it works as a
payment system, and what you think the need
is that this is trying to address?
ANDRESEN: So if you think about the payment
systems we have today, you know, they're typically
created back in pencil-and-paper days.
So we have, you know, check-clearing payment
systems that have kind of evolved, and they
kind of work today.
Although, if you try to pay somebody, it might
take three or four, five days, depending on
whether there's a bank holiday in the middle
of, you know, when you wrote your check, when
it actually gets to the other person's bank
account.
And that's kind of crazy, right.
I mean, I can send an e-mail across the world,
and it arrives in that person's inbox in five
seconds, 10 seconds.
When you're talking about money these days,
I mean, you're talking about numbers in bank
accounts.
Why does it take two, three, four, five days
to transfer value to somebody across the world?
The reason is, it evolved, right.
It was not designed -- our payment systems
were not designed for the Internet.
Bitcoin was designed for the Internet.
It's fundamentally secure at a very low level,
using up-to-date cryptography, you know, using
kind of best practices for how do you make
sure that the person you're paying is the
person you're paying, and nobody can get in
the middle of that.
And so as a payment system, it's just much
more efficient than the payment systems we've
had up to this point.
And because it's more efficient, it's cheaper,
faster, better.
It also doesn't care about international boundaries,
which I mean, there's lots of regulations
set up around national borders, which in the
age of the Internet, you really have to ask
yourself, does that make sense anymore, right?
We're a globally-connected world.
I can send e-mail across the world.
I don't have to go to the national post office,
and then put a stamp, that then goes to some
other national post office.
I just send e-mail.
It just goes.
It's the Internet.
And so Bitcoin's designed for the Internet,
designed to be efficient.
And so as a payment system, you know, lots
of people are seeing opportunities to make
things better, cheaper, faster, for consumers.
REDIKER: All right.
So let's break that down for a minute.
So the existing payment system structure is
slow, inefficient, for, I would argue, many
reasons; one of which is, as you say, it was
written initially for the paper-and-pen crowd.
And it has evolved in a slapdash kind of way.
But the other is that there are actual impediments
set up for a reason, so regulators would say,
"We have the need to know where funds are
coming from, where they're going to."
There are banks that play the role of intermediaries,
both to make money, and also to abide by a
regulatory or a legal framework that is both
country by country, and some international
norms.
Those could be seen as either the -- promoting
the common good, or as rent-seeking, and those
intermediaries are simply trying to make their,
you know, 2 percent on somebody else's hard
work.
But there's clearly some element of both involved
here.
So whereas on the rent-seeking, you can argue
that Bitcoin and this kind of technology advance
is a good thing.
It does run the risk of allowing people to
bypass all the regulatory infrastructure that
exists out there.
And that leaves it prone to challenge that
its basically for people who want to avoid
regulatory and legal oversight.
We've seen those challenges play out both
in terms of the press, terms of skeptical
regulators, in terms of recent events we can
get into in a moment.
But, you know, what's the pushback on, yes,
it's great, because it allows us to avoid
all of the friction, when a lot of people
would say some friction is there for a reason?
ANDRESEN: I may get myself in trouble.
REDIKER: Then I will have done my job this
morning.
ANDRESEN: Personally -- you know, personally,
I think regulation's always about weighing
risks, costs, and benefits.
And so, you know, I think -- I'm not going
to tell regulators how to do their job.
I would just encourage them to -- I think
regulators tend to focus on costs and risks,
and not to focus so much on benefits.
Although, I must say, I think, actually, the
regulators here in the U.S. have actually
done a pretty good job of realizing that,
you know, there is a balance to be struck.
And if there are tremendous benefits, then
even if there are additional risks, if the
benefits outweigh the risks, then the rational
thing to do is to, you know, allow -- or not
try to impede progress.
And so, yes, I obviously think the benefits
of Bitcoin are huge.
The potential is huge.
And that's why I'm working on it, right.
I wouldn't work on it if I thought it was
going to make the world a horrible place.
Other people might disagree, although, so
far, I mean, it seems like most smart people
who've looked at Bitcoin really closely, they
see the value proposition.
They see that there are these huge benefits.
And it will remain to be seen, you know, how
well regulators, governments, law enforcement,
adapt.
I think on a larger scale, going through this
with just the Internet in general, right,
of how does government adapt to this kind
of new communication mechanism that lets people
all over the world maybe talk about things
that we wouldn't want them talking about,
that let's them interact in ways that they
weren't able to interact before.
So like I said, I don't have the answers.
I think you just need to carefully look at
both the benefits and the costs.
REDIKER: So from your perspective then -- and
this is not meant to be definitive -- but
the idea of some regulatory mechanism is not
totally off the table.
So the idea of a bit license, I think some
regulators have talked about, we don't know
what that would look like, and maybe you know.
But that's not a total nonstarter.
It's not all or nothing in terms of no government
having anything to do with it, or total clamp-down,
as in the case of, I think China has prohibited
Bitcoin.
There's some middle ground that you think
might be an acceptable future?
ANDRESEN: I mean, for me personally, you know,
I think things like consumer protection make
sense, you know.
You should have some idea of who you're interacting
with if you're trusting them with money, or
whatever.
So things like that I think make a lot of
sense.
Trying to control Bitcoin, I think a government
like North Korea will probably be very successful
in controlling Bitcoin, just in the same way
they've been successful in controlling the
access to the Internet.
For other, you know, more liberal governments
around the world, it's going to be tough to
tell your citizens, you know, "Don't buy shoes
from somebody in this particular country,
because we don't like that country."
That's going to be hard to enforce.
So, you know, even though a regulator might
want to have that control, I'm not sure it's
even possible to...
REDIKER: Well, the buying shoes, there's a
physical good that's being transferred.
So there are obviously -- just to use that
example, the alpaca socks.
They're coming across the border, they've
got to be physically transferred.
There's a means by which the government can
deal with that.
A transfer of funding, obviously, is the other
side of it.
And that's harder to control.
So let me move on to the other aspect of this,
which is the virtual currency side.
I think that's where I'm more skeptical.
Anything that goes from half a penny to $1,000
in a very short period of time, and then has
a huge amount of volatility in the meantime,
gives you pause to question whether the basic
economic theory of what a currency is supposed
to be, store of value, medium of exchange,
and unit of account on the store of value
side, that leads people to say, "Well, hold
on now."
That's not just currency fluctuation.
That's a pretty dramatic shift.
Can you walk me through why we need a new
virtual currency -- not the payment system
side -- but why we might need a new virtual
currency?
And then I'll probably push back on some of
the basics of what a central bank's role in
the world is, or ought to be, and whether
in fact something like Bitcoin is consistent
with that.
ANDRESEN: Yes, it's interesting.
I mean, I'll get myself in trouble again,
this time, with a different audience.
If Bitcoin turns out to be a miserable failure,
which I should say, it's still possible.
It could be a miserable failure for technical
reasons, or sociological reasons, or monetary
reasons.
But if it's a miserable failure, but it does
encourage some government somewhere around
the world to realize that our payment systems
are really broken and archaic, and some country
decides we're going to create a payment system
for this century that's -- where the currency
is, you know, our national currency, I think
that would be a huge success.
Just that would add so much value to the world
of creating a way of -- it really doesn't
matter if the currency is dollars or euros,
or loonies.
I think -- actually, the Canadian government's
actually been pretty -- done some interesting
experiments with putting Canadian dollars
in digital form.
Or you can look at what's happening with M-Pesa
in Africa, very innovative payment system
with the Kenyan schilling being the backing
currency.
So if that's the only kind of effect that
Bitcoin has, as kind of showing the way, then
I think, you know, Bitcoin will have been
a success.
The argument for why Bitcoin, the currency,
there's several things that people bring up.
So one is kind of the fixed supply, right.
Everybody knows it's completely and utterly
predictable how many bitcoins there will be
next week.
You know, we know that they're being created
at a rate of 25 approximately every 10 minutes.
That rate is fixed in the code, and it, you
know, kind of self-adjusts.
People all over the world are getting those
25 bitcoins.
It's not, you know, one person issuing the
currency.
And the economic theory is that if you know
that there's a fixed supply, and assuming
that demand settles down, that, you know,
eventually everybody in the world will have
heard about Bitcoin, hopefully, and all the
people who want to use Bitcoin are using it,
then, you know, you have a predictable demand.
And if supply and demand are both reasonably
stable, then you get a stable price.
Because the price is purely driven by supply
and demand.
Whether that's ever going to happen, nobody
really knows.
Whether that's actually the correct economic
theory, you know, economists I think will
argue about endlessly, maybe for years and
years.
I still say Bitcoin's an experiment.
And it's an experiment in progress.
And we'll have to see.
But, you know, I mean, theoretically, if you
think about it, what if a government did decide
-- what if the Canadian government decided,
you know, "Our currency is going to be a virtual
currency.
We're going to, you know, upgrade our payment
system, so anybody anywhere in the world can
use it," would other countries trust the Canadian
government to do the right thing, to always
uphold their end of the bargain?
I think the U.S. government would probably
have a big issue with kind of saying to its
citizens, "Yes, you guys should start using
this cool currency the Canadian government
invented."
So a currency like Bitcoin, where there's
nobody in charge, there's no country in charge,
there's no corporation in charge, it's everybody
who's using the currency is supporting the
currency, theoretically might be something
that everybody could agree, since there's
no one person in charge, "Yes, this is something
that we could all use."
REDIKER: So I'm going to push back.
First of all, the fixed demand is a question
I would push back on, because not only is
there not fixed demand in any given quarter,
month, year, but over time, the population
of the earth grows, and economic growth continues
to hopefully be a dynamic.
So over time, you do have both volatility
in demand, but a steady, upward trend in demand.
And if you cap the amount of supply, then
by definition, you're going to have an imbalance
at some point in the future, which is why
there are those who are skeptical for, amongst
other reasons, for the inherent deflationary
aspects of Bitcoin; meaning that if Bitcoin
continues to go up in value, because you've
got a fixed supply, and a potentially increasing
demand over the long term, then by definition,
if the value of the currency goes up, then
the value of what it can buy goes down.
And therefore, you have deflation, which,
you know, in the generation of those in this
room, is somewhat of a new phenomenon that
we're talking about in Europe right now, the
risks of deflation; the Fed in the U.S. having
fought off the risks of deflation in the post-financial-crisis
era.
So it's one thing to say this potentially
takes care of your inflationary problems.
But don't central banks play a valuable role
in using all of their economic and discretionary
tools to actually adjust both interest rates
and the supply of money, precisely because
the world is a messy place, and things don't
always go as a software program might predict
that they should?
And you need this human element in there,
precisely as we've seen over the past several
years, to adjust the money supply and interest
rates, to take account of what's going on
in the real world.
ANDRESEN: Yes.
I don't know.
I mean, if you talk to most Bitcoiners, they
would say, no, central banks have done a horrible
job.
In my wallet, I actually keep some foreign
currency.
I keep a $100 trillion Reserve note from Zimbabwe
-- it was issued in 2009 -- which is, you
know, that's an extreme example of a central
bank screwing up, either on purpose or accidentally.
As a technology person, you know, deflation
doesn't bother me, right.
That iPad that you're holding, you couldn't
buy it 10 years ago.
If you could buy it, I don't know how many
millions of dollars it would cost, right.
We certainly have rapid deflation in the high-tech
world, and just in terms of the things we
can buy.
We seem to do OK with that, you know.
I mean, Apple seems to be doing OK, even though
you know next year there's going to be a fancier
version of that, that you're going to want.
So I'm not an economist.
You know, I know that there's all sorts of
theories about sticky wages and, how could
you write contracts in a currency if it's
deflationary?
Again, I don't know.
Bitcoin's an experiment.
I think these are questions that, if Bitcoin
continues to be successful, maybe it will
have to worry about in 20, 30, 40 years -- I
don't know what the world is going to be like
in 20, 30, 40 years.
But they're certainly fascinating, interesting
questions, I think are going to be debated
for quite a while.
REDIKER: Speaking of fascinating and interesting
questions, it is at the witching hour of 9
o'clock, which means I'm going to open it
up to the audience for your fascinating and
interesting questions.
So I think I've got something I was supposed
to say here.
Hold on, let me see.
Right.
Please wait for the microphone.
Speak directly into it.
Please stand and say your name and affiliation.
Keep your questions and comments concise to
allow as many attendees as possible to speak.
So I'm going to start right here.
Wait for the mike, please.
QUESTION: Hi, Danny Frifeld (ph).
I'm sorry if I missed this, but I'm having
a hard time extricating the payment mechanism
from the underlying instrument.
I get the attractiveness of the mechanism.
But what is the -- if the underlying instrument
has some attractiveness, and now it's got
fixed demand -- fixed supply, rather -- and
so it's a store value, or it provides some
predictability, that it's not going to be
subject to such rampant inflationary pressures,
that it'll lose all value.
But why – again -- notwithstanding what
the central bank may do wrong in this country,
but the dollar is effectively serving that
purpose, along with a couple other currencies.
So I know you've alluded to, if the one contribution
Bitcoin made to humanity was dragging along
the improvement of payment mechanisms around
the world.
But I still -- what I'm sort of missing, is
that, you know, there are other systems, again,
all rent-seeking, like credit cards and PayPal
and the like.
But what's really the attractiveness of the
instrument behind this as a store of value,
beyond something like gold or the dollar?
ANDRESEN: I think the attractiveness is the
fixed supply, right.
If you know that there will only ever be 21
million bitcoins in the world, and you have
one of them, I mean, you have one-twenty-one-millionth
of that commodity.
And nobody can take it away from you.
And that's another key part of Bitcoin.
If you own bitcoins, you actually own them.
It's like cash in that way.
They exist as these long numbers, essentially,
that can't be taken away from you.
Nobody -- until you sign a transaction that
transfers the value somewhere else, you own
them.
You can print them out on a piece of paper,
and put them in your safe-deposit box.
I actually have a bitcoin in my wallet that
I can show you, that, you know, has that number
on it.
And so if you're looking for some other store
of value, something like gold works, right.
If you own gold, you actually do own it.
It's, you know, sitting -- you can hide it
under your mattress.
But it's not convenient to trade, right.
And so Bitcoin combines a really interesting
-- it's both a commodity that you really do
own when you own bitcoins.
But it's also incredibly convenient to trade,
because it's, you know, a creature of the
Internet.
If I want to send a bitcoin, sit down at my
computer, sign a transaction, send it anywhere
in the world.
So I think that's, as a store of value, as
a, you know, a commodity, as a token, that's
why so many people find it valuable.
REDIKER: I just picked up on this.
I saw a study last night as I was preparing
for this, saying that 64 percent of all bitcoins
are hoarded, or are not used.
So just as a make-believe economist, let me
just throw out that the purpose of currency
is to be used, so that they are used to stimulate
economic activity, which feeds growth and
jobs, and all that good stuff.
So if the limited supply means you know it's
going to increase in value over time, you're
not getting into deflation versus inflation,
but the fact that I know I've got it doesn't
actually help the broader, global economy,
because I'm not using it to stimulate economic
activity, which ought to be a pretty fundamental
tenet of why you use a currency.
ANDRESEN: I mean, in theory, that's true.
In practice, it doesn't seem to work out that
way.
So BitPay is a large Bitcoin payment processor.
You can think of them as like the PayPal for
Bitcoin.
They help merchants accept payments for goods
and services in Bitcoin.
And they tell me that as the Bitcoin price
rises, they see more transactions.
So people are doing exactly the opposite.
And it might just be a wealth effect, where,
"I bought some bitcoins for $100, they're
now worth $200 apiece.
I have $100 I can spend, right, without -- I
might as well spend it.
It's basically free money."
And I think you might see some of that.
And I think that's something that people will
want to hold onto bitcoins as kind of -- eventually,
the idea would be to hold onto bitcoins as
a safe store of value, just like you might
put, you know, cash under your mattress if
you don't trust the banks, if you don't trust
anybody else.
It's generally a bad idea, cash under the
mattress, in case you have a house fire, whatever.
Bitcoins could function as a high-tech, easier
to kind of back up cash under the mattress.
And I think there will always be some of that.
You could call that hoarding.
You can call that saving -- savings.
But if the price goes high enough, and there's
something you want to buy, I think you will
-- certainly, I paid for my hotel room here,
actually, using Bitcoin.
And was very happy to do it, and actually
saved a little bit of money, because the company
that's doing it saves on credit-card fees
when they use Bitcoin instead of...
So, you know, we'll see.
In practice, it doesn't seem to be an issue.
QUESTION: I was told to stand.
My name is Carter Dougherty.
I'm with Bloomberg News.
I'm a resident bitcoiniac, bitcoin boy, call
me what you will.
I think it's safe to say that when you look
at these functions of the store of value versus
the medium of exchange, the area that's attracted
the most attention in the sense of venture
capital, and serious investment, has been
the medium-of-exchange concept, whether you're
looking at Coinbase, or Circle Financial in
Boston, that sort of thing.
And that's really what attracts the people
who thought about this for a long time, because
Bitcoin shows all the signs of being a disruptive
payment system that doesn't simply piggyback
on the existing system, which, if you think
about it, is really what PayPal has done.
Do you think that over time, if the sort of
commercial evolution is in that direction,
of this focus on the medium of exchange, will
the enthusiasts, the ur-enthusiasts, the developers,
the engineers, the ideas people, will they
maintain their interests and focus on Bitcoin
and digital currency?
Because there is -- we all heard the sort
of disdain in your voice when you mentioned
central banks.
I mean, this is a widespread kind of libertarian
bent of many bitcoiniacs.
Would that -- is the enthusiasm going to continue
if we move in this other direction?
ANDRESEN: I think so.
We'll see.
There's -- I mean, there's so much potential
with Bitcoin.
I mean, we're really -- like I said, I get
excited about all the interesting things that
can be done with this new technology, right.
I'm a technology guy, so I'm always thinking
about what's going to be next.
And so people, like venture capitalists, will
look at just kind of the meat and potatoes,
you know, "What industries that are already
incredibly profitable can we disrupt?
How can we get a piece of that trillion-dollar
industry, and make a bunch of money?"
That's not that interesting to me, personally.
I think there's enough kind of meat there.
Bitcoin's such an interesting kind of revolutionary
disruptive technology, that I think it will
keep people's interest, even while we have,
you know, lots of money being thrown at kind
of how do you optimize the existing infrastructure
and payment system, and work in the existing
system?
So I think we're going to have both.
You know, as chief scientist at the Bitcoin
Foundation, kind of my -- part of my job is
to encourage lots of different experiments
in lots of different areas, and to see, you
know -- well, to make sure that the fundamental
technology keeps chugging away, processing
transactions reliably, and then to let, you
know, all this wonderful innovation and experimentation
happen on top.
So...
REDIKER: In the back.
QUESTION: Hi, John Stubbs.
You touched on a few of these.
But I was just wondering what you see as the
biggest, or most significant, existential
threat to Bitcoin in the next two to three
years?
ANDRESEN: I have a deep respect for, you know,
threats that are like an asteroid that you
didn't know was there, coming, and like wiping
out the dinosaurs, you know.
So I always have trouble answering this question,
because I think the biggest -- probably the
biggest threat is something that just isn't
on my radar.
I have no idea.
You know, maybe there's somebody working in
his basement that has a system that's 10 times
better than Bitcoin, and will come out with
it.
And you know, just -- everybody says, "Oh,
that's way better.
We'll just use that instead of Bitcoin."
It's possible.
You know, that's -- I don't think it's likely.
But that's possible.
It's possible that society in general decides
Bitcoin's a bad idea; that, you know, maybe
crazy, high-tech people think it's the greatest
thing ever.
Ordinary people just think it's unpatriotic.
They think it's -- whatever.
You know, that could happen, and that could,
you know, make it basically be a tiny little
niche that's only used by maybe unsavory people,
and it fails, because nobody wants to be associated
with something that's only used for unsavory
purposes.
A technical glitch is certainly possible.
As we scale up the Bitcoin network, I get
kept up at night worrying that we're going
to introduce some bug in the code that, you
know, maybe we need to deploy some software
that everybody uses.
And then, unbeknownst to us, there's some
bug that brings the network down for a day
or two.
That could really shake confidence in this
payment system; that, you know, a payment
system that goes down for a couple days is
not a payment system you want to rely on.
Although, I guess there are existing banking
payment systems, kind of go down every weekend.
So maybe that's not an existential threat.
But, you know, those are the kinds of things
that I think about.
But again, asteroid killing the dinosaurs
might be out there that I just don't know
about.
QUESTION: Thank you.
Ornstein Mallock (ph) from the State Department.
Quick question.
For technology to really go mass, you normally
need it to be elegant.
So Bitcoin may be mathematically, and from
a cryptography perspective, very elegant,
from a user perspective.
So one bitcoin, for instance, costs $800.
So if the average person on the street wants
to get a bitcoin, it's very expensive.
And so you need to have smaller denominations.
And I know that right now, people buy zero-point-zero-zero-zero
-- whatever -- bitcoin.
That's not very elegant.
And it has to be like the iPad, something
which is, you know, user-friendly.
Is there some effort being made to make it
more elegant, more user-friendly in that regard?
ANDRESEN: Absolutely.
I mean, a part of the excitement in Silicon
Valley is, you know, startups that are trying
to make really easy ways for people to buy
Bitcoin, easy ways for people to trade Bitcoin,
easy ways for people to make their Bitcoin
secure.
I saw, I think just yesterday, the day before,
there's announcement of a little wrist thing
that can hold your bitcoins.
And it monitors your heart.
And apparently, our heartbeats are unique.
And so, you know, somebody steals your wrist
thing, they can't steal your bitcoins, because
they don't have your same heartbeat, which
is wild and crazy.
And I don't know if that will succeed or not,
but that's an example of kind of one of the
experiments of what people are doing to make
it really easy for people to use Bitcoin to
keep them secure.
And we will see that.
I mean, you're right.
Buying -- there's this idea that you have
to buy one bitcoin, which is not true.
You can buy one-thousandth of the bitcoin.
I think we'll see kind of, from a bottom-up,
emergent process.
We might start talking about milli bitcoins,
millies, instead of bitcoins.
So I'll send you two millies for that cup
of coffee, or whatever.
That's going to be a bottom-up.
I think that'll be a bottom-up process.
I don't know, you could imagine the Bitcoin
Foundation taking the lead in saying, "We
think that this nomenclature shall be the
nomenclature," although, that's really not
in the spirit of the bitcoin.
The spirit of Bitcoin is more to kind of let
that kind of thing emerge.
QUESTION: Marvin Amore (ph), the New America
Foundation.
There's a lot of excitement in the human-rights
community around Bitcoin.
And I know that WordPress.com allows bloggers
around the world who might be anonymous to
pay with Bitcoin.
So I'm wondering if you've seen anything interesting
around human rights and Bitcoin.
And also, since we're at the Council on Foreign
Relations, any thoughts on foreign policy
and Bitcoin, sort of foreign aid?
Anything you could write in the code to constrain
or monitor where American foreign aid might
go, if given in Bitcoin, or another altcoin?
ANDRESEN: Yes.
I mean, you know, on the benefit side, you
know, bringing kind of a stable payment network
to people in the world that really haven't
had that, you know, a stable, modern payment
network, to anybody who has, you know, a smartphone,
or even a dumb phone -- I think smartphones,
you know, in five years, I think pretty much
everybody in the world will have a smartphone,
right.
That's just the process of technology, right.
iPhones are expensive.
Fifteen years from now, you'll have an iPhone
given away in your Cheerios, as, you know,
your little toy.
It's the wonderful thing about technology.
It just gets cheaper.
And so I think there is huge opportunity there,
and that there are people, you know, working
hard on making Bitcoin usable in places in
the world that don't have a lot of infrastructure.
And so there's a lot of -- I think there will
be a lot of innovation happening there.
And that's fantastic.
And it'll be even more fantastic if the people
doing that innovation are the people in those
countries.
I want to see a lot more of that.
For foreign aid, I don't know much about the
foreign-aid world.
I mean, one of the interesting things about
Bitcoin, is it's this distributed ledger,
where if you want, you can be incredibly transparent
about, you know, "These are the bitcoins that
are coming in, and these are the bitcoins
going out."
And we have this data structure called the
"block chain," where anybody can audit it.
So, you know, if you publish, "These are all
my bitcoin transactions that I got in, these
are all the bitcoin transactions that I got
out, that went out," and, you know, "This
is my bitcoin balance," you know, anybody
can audit that, and you don't need to go visit
some corporate offices, and pour through records.
It's out there in the public.
So I think that's actually part of Bitcoin
that hasn't been explored much at all, is
how do you -- how can you use it as a very
transparent payment system, so that a non-profit
can be completely upfront with their finances,
and everybody can trust that the money is
actually going to what they say it's going
to.
I just want to throw one other thing.
I was really excited last week to give money
to a charity called, "Give Directly," which
has the simplest model in the world for a
charity.
They find poor people, and they give them
money.
That's it.
Incredibly low overhead.
I believe they're operating in Kenya -- Kenya
and Uganda at the moment.
And they just -- I asked them if they would
accept bitcoin donations, and actually got
to beta-test their bitcoin donation process,
and gave them some bitcoins, that they will
then turn around, and give directly to poor
people in Africa, which I think is just a
fantastic -- and, you know, they're turning
it into cash, and they're actually transferring
that cash overseas, and turning it into Kenyan
schillings, and then it goes, Kenyan schillings
to the M-Pesa system, which works on, you
know, phones.
If the poor person doesn't actually have a
cheap cell phone, they'll actually give them
a phone, so that they can receive the money.
Then they have it basically on their phone.
And all of that process, there's all sorts
of friction there.
But we could do a lot better, right.
It would be much better if I could donate
bitcoins to them, and then they just turn
around and send the bitcoins directly to the
poor farmers in Africa.
And then they'd trade them amongst themselves.
That's the vision.
And that's where I hope we get.
And that's the kind of thing that, you know,
makes me excited, makes me want to work on
Bitcoin more.
REDIKER: Right here in the middle.
QUESTION: Hi, Sean Goldheart (ph) of Barclays.
So on the side, I run a charity.
And we get virtual currency, not Bitcoin.
Well, at least, not yet.
But if you guys are giving more out, we'd
love to take it.
It's been great, because we are able to get
cash for it, computers for our kids, suits
for the children, whatever we need, which,
it's always interesting, because when a new
vendor comes on the system, we get very excited,
because it's somewhere new we can spend our
money.
And I think of Bitcoin now as like American
Express points.
You can use it in New York City cabs.
You can trade it for cash.
You can trade it for a flight or an iPad.
How much time do you guys spend trying to
find new vendors, versus vendors coming to
you, because they see this as like a popular
item of exchange?
Because the way -- I don't -- I think if an
asteroid's going to come hit the earth, in
my opinion, nobody's going to want Bitcoin.
You're going to want a military behind your
dollar.
And a bunch of guys in Silicon Valley are
not going to protect me.
So I see Bitcoin having a limited -- not a
limited -- having a use as the ability, like
American Express points are to buy certain
things.
But it only works if a lot of vendors accept
it.
And it feels like now more and more vendors
are beginning to accept Bitcoin.
So what's the effort you guys are making to
find more vendors to accept it, to kind of
ward off these other virtual currencies?
ANDRESEN: Well, you say, "you guys," which
is not correct.
There is no "you guys" with Bitcoin.
With Bitcoin, it's everybody.
It could be you.
There's no central -- I mean, the Bitcoin
Foundation exists as a trade organization
to talk to regulators, to give information
to people who, like, are trying to get their
hands around this weird, decentralized system.
So I know, for example, the folks at BitPay
and Coinbase, which are two bitcoin -- big
bitcoin companies here in the United States,
they spend a lot of time talking to merchants,
you know.
I know -- I don't remember if it was BitPay
or Coinbase, that did the Overstock.com deal.
Coinbase?
Coinbase.
So they spent time, you know, talking to Overstock.com
CEO, and selling it to him, and getting Overstock.com
to accept bitcoin.
That's being replicated all over the world.
So entrepreneurs are kind of -- people will
send me e-mails saying, "I would like to do
this or that with Bitcoin.
May I?"
And my response is, "You don't have to ask
anybody's permission or advice."
It's an open system.
Anybody can jump in and do whatever they want
with it, subject to whatever regulations exist
in your jurisdiction.
That's, you know, part of what some of the
early entrepreneurs are finding, is that there
are things that you -- just because you're
using Bitcoin, doesn't make you immune from
regulation, prosecution.
I think, to me, that's like, "Duh."
But, you know, I think there was kind of some
feeling that it would be this kind of magical
fairy dust that would let you sidestep all
of the existing legal and regulatory framework.
And that's just not true.
REDIKER: How about tax?
ANDRESEN: Tax?
REDIKER: I mean, you know, regulation, know
your client, that's one thing.
But, you know, societies generally exist with
at lest some element of tax revenue.
Is there a general understanding and acceptance
of Bitcoin Foundation and the broad bitcoin
universe, that even if it is an anonymous
transfer, there is an obligation at the end
of the day to pay your fair share of taxes?
ANDRESEN: Yes.
I mean, my salary every month, I get paid
in bitcoin.
So I get bitcoin transferred to one of my
Bitcoin addresses.
But before that happens, your taxes are taken
out, and are paid in dollars, just as if I
had any other job.
And while we wish the IRS would be a little
more clear about exactly, you know, when taxable
events occur, and I think that will happen.
But yes.
I mean, Bitcoin is really not all that different
from other things in the world that are taxed,
like foreign currency transactions, or barter
transactions, or -- usually there's some kind
of pigeon hole in the regulatory framework
that Bitcoin might not fit in perfectly, but
probably fits in well enough.
And taxing authorities all over the world
are currently scratching their heads and trying
to figure out which pigeon hole to put Bitcoin
in.
REDIKER: Gentleman in the back.
QUESTION: Hey, Gavin.
I'm John Flam (ph) with the Air Force.
So you had mentioned earlier the term, "unsavory
people."
And this -- we were talking about non-profits,
and how transparent these transactions are,
which is great and all.
But with that term, "unsavory people," one
thing that comes to mind, in my small brain
anyways, is terrorist financing, money laundering,
those sorts of things.
And so on the court of public opinion, it's
probably important that people want to contribute
to an organization that, you know, does not
condone that, right.
So with that said, like how -- and I'm sure
you've been asked this question before.
How do you deter unsavory people from participating
in Bitcoin, and this type of transaction?
ANDRESEN: That's a really good question for
law enforcement, and in the Senate hearings,
end of last year, we heard from law enforcement
that they felt like they already have the
tools that they need to deter people.
And I think we've seen that with like the
closure of the Silk Road drug marketplace,
where -- thinking about it purely from a technical
point of view, I think once you get to a size
that's kind of large enough to be interesting,
it gets really hard to pull off whatever criminal
enterprise, you know, you're trying to pull
off.
And so I think we'll see naturally kind of
these little Silk Roads start out as this
tiny little place on the hidden Internet.
They got big enough that the founder had to
start hiring people to help with that customer
support.
Once you have more than like one or two people
involved, I think it becomes really hard for
criminal organization to function, you know,
to not get caught; especially with a system
like Bitcoin, where all these transactions
are being recorded in this global, public
ledger.
And the more -- just the more people you interact
with, the more opportunity there is for somebody
to actually turn out to be working for law
enforcement, which I think is a big part of
why Silk Road got taken down.
So I think the standard law enforcement techniques
of infiltration, of surveillance, of all the
other tools they have at their disposal, will
work with Bitcoin, just like they work with
people who are smuggling diamonds, or transferring
cash across borders, or, you know, doing what
other unsavory stuff.
REDIKER: We've got time for one more question.
Before I take it, I just want remind everyone
this meeting is on the record.
So last question.
Gentleman back here.
QUESTION: Hi.
I'm Garrett Graff.
I'm editor of Washingtonian Magazine, and
a proud bitcoin owner.
But I'm not Satoshi Nakamoto.
So I can help you narrow that down a little
bit.
I'm curious.
We've talked about it in a couple of different
contexts.
If you would just talk a little bit about,
as the -- while I understand, there are not
"you guys" at Bitcoin.
You are, to a certain extent, the public face
of sort of Bitcoin, Inc.
And I'm curious if you would talk a little
bit about -- I assume you have had some level
of interaction with various entities of the
United States government, and sort of what
those interactions have been, and what the
reaction you've gotten from -- your interactions
have been?
ANDRESEN: Well, I gave a talk at the CIA a
couple years ago.
And they're really good at not talking back.
They're well trained.
So, you know, on some level, I don't know.
My interactions with regulators have typically
been very open.
I mean, the fantastic thing about working
on Bitcoin is we really don't have any secrets,
right.
I mean, we're very upfront about -- we're
an open-source software project.
Here's the code.
Here's how it works.
Here's where the money comes from.
Here's where it goes.
So it's pretty -- it's actually pretty easy
to talk to government, to just kind of put
it out there as, you know, here's what the
technology does.
We're not going to say what it means, or what's
going to happen in the future, but, you know,
I think the interactions have been generally
pretty positive.
I think they've generally been pretty positive
because we have been so open.
I mean, we're not trying to do anything nefarious
here.
And I think everybody working on -- at least
everybody I know working on Bitcoin is doing
it for the reason that we think it'll make
the world a better place.
We think it'll just make our lives better.
And so, you know, whether we can convince
every regulator in the world of that or not,
I don't think we will.
But, you know, so far, at least here in the
U.S., it feels like, you know, we've been
successful in that message, that we really
do think that the benefits of Bitcoin are
going to make the world a better place.
REDIKER: Fabulous way to end.
I'm still a little bit of a skeptic on the
whether central banks play a positive role
or not, but we'll leave that for another day.
But I think we all learned a lot this morning.
I think you put forth a great case.
And we all wish you the best.
And thank you all for coming.
(APPLAUSE)